there are many things that are in common
between thinking about addition
subtraction of functions and
multiplication of division of functions
for instance the first thing I'm going
to do is I'm going to look at these
components and I'm going to graph the
component I'm in fact before I go any
further let's do that okay so we've got
y equals x I know exactly what that
looks like and then you've got you can
see it there written I just did a bit
lazy shorthand
they've written their like sir log base
e of X we'll spend lots and lots of time
on it it's already introduced that very
briefly before but as an abbreviated way
of writing log base e of X because E is
the natural number of exponential growth
the abbreviation gets is L and for log
natural actually there's like a Latin
thing that is why it's in different
order we would usually say natural log
but that's what LM means it beads
basic okay the natural log is going to
look like every other log except for the
scale is a bit different okay now as you
seen we're trying to make visually I'll
give it to you so the scale is like the
amost important thing here I'm just
going to draw it roughly this is the
kind of graph I'm getting and of course
I'm asymptotic to the y axis but I'm not
going to put that on there because I
think you have that you're quiet okay so
there are our component graphs now
that's the first thing that I roll
around that's the first thing that I
notice which is the same in order to
make a visual argument you need the
pieces on it but there are some things
obviously particularly quite different
right for example I'm not at all
thinking about like the ordinates and
going up and going down in terms of just
adding the numbers multiplication works
completely differently right so excuse
me for instance the same critical points
that I noticed before are going to be
important to me here just like they were
an addition and subtraction
okay so for instance see this guy here
this is the x intercept of the natural
log right so it's 0 that's the ordinate
there you
zero now be orden up here because I
happen to know what the x value is for
this well it's the x value yeah it's one
the x value up here one will be there's
a y-value one up there right so this one
will be 0 and this one we won but as it
turns out I don't really care what that
wouldn't it is right because 0 times
anything is 0
so when I multiply the ordinate 0 times
anything any any of the functions that
are my components if they have Ritz then
the whole composite function will also
have roots assuming all the components
exist which brings me to my other
important point over here you're like oh
y equals x that has an x intercept right
but it's a bit different right why is it
different it doesn't it doesn't wait
what does it exist very good one of the
components doesn't exist do you remember
we said that the domain of our composite
function right is the intersection of
the domains of everything else right you
can see log X it only exists over here
for X is greater than zero okay so this
is super funny I don't exist there right
because this graph doesn't exist there
if this graph did exist where would I go
like if this existed anywhere where was
the composite function be it would be
here right because it'd be 0 times
something would be 0 right now being an
icon exists I'm going to put an open
circle right there because I can't
actually get there if log X had a value
there
I both wanted to get up.get 0 but it
doesn't exist so I have a hollow circle
okay all right now what other arguments
can I make on this based on how these
things are working together okay yeah
suggestion
okay fantastic
so this guy's really well he's just
heading up along the way this guy is
also heading up but at certain points
he's shallow and it's certain 20 steep
okay so I'm going to use that in a
second for instance where I'm doing this
time times this guy and they're both
increasing right so if you're
multiplying two things that are
increasing what would you expect when I
put them all together it's it's still
increasing right in fact it's even more
impressive so you're going to get an
awkward graph like this like it can't go
anywhere else right you also know
because you've got positive times
positive but the sign of the product
will be positive okay
now I'm actually going to use that as my
segue to work out well if I'm going up
here that's nice
but what about in this little spot yeah
think about on either helping in fact
Alliance right you've ever needed
rational functions emitted positive is a
region factor lines that's what I have
here these are the factors so they're my
factors right so I've got negative times
positive negative is positive will be
negative so therefore I know that here
I'm in this lower region of here here I
got positive to positive so I've got
this region up here and then I've got
these three points to connect between I
am guessing it's gonna do something like
this okay now this is my guess okay this
is my guest is do you see how it fits
into all the things that I know so far
right for instance I know that I'm
negative in here I've never got a point
which I always get to and a point that I
actually get to and I'm in my region and
then up here it just grows okay do I
have any other information that could
kind of confirm for me but this might be
what's doable
are you talking about KU cavity like as
it is it increasing or is it decreasing
and the answer is yes it does okay now
the question the kid is asking is do I
go up like this or do I go off like that
okay now I have information on the graph
that does indicate for me which one of
the two it is okay what do you reckon I
can rap you wanna give a solution okay
so for sports so I've got two here and
E's like two point seven ish so if
that's three then is somewhere around
there yep go ahead well slow down slow
down slow
I think you must half the class okay so
say it again but slow up you said when
now see if you can follow what's going
on right you've got this point here okay
which is at E now this is this graph the
the little log graph is log base e of X
right so if X is e and this is log base
E of eight that's the number you raise e
to so you get eaten then number is one
right
so therefore this coordinate ought to
come over to one that's the ordinate
yeah okay go ahead kick on
which is good good good good okay all
right
in case you didn't catch up it's exactly
right but it's a bit hard because I have
the blackboard marker and you're trying
to do a visual thing verbally okay and
you've also well I just haven't finished
going what was the argument think about
the ordinance again right so at this
point my X values me and my ordinate
right there is one okay remember how we
made the argument but zero times
anything is zero well 1 times anything
is the anything whatever that happens to
be which is up here somewhere right
so I'm going to be going through here
yes now I actually like that's not too
bad it probably could have gone through
there if I'd kept it going so you're
going to get an intersection point up
there that'd be a comma a ok now that's
good doesn't quite answer our question
about concavity okay like is it going to
keep on getting steeper or is it going
to plateau out like the log curve does
anyone else want to make an additional
suggestions Jack it's gonna flood in
there okay so one suggestion is we go
for let's call this state bar and we'll
call this one flat okay how are we gonna
work out which one it does how are we
gonna work this out before you before
you go around anyone else would make a
suggestion because this is actually this
is the whole point of it and I don't
want to just give you the answer I want
to try and logic it out why
which is it's like so it's neither
correct yep
and so when you times that by something
like even if that your own ex is going
like immediately flat mm-hmm and these
little times in your wife's face by
something which means it was still be
going on okay hold on
say that last bit again slowly because I
know what you're talking but that's cuz
I don't the answer it is right see me
say it again and see if people can catch
it again your argument was about this
can you repeat it again so even if that
kind of plan is kind of a lot of itself
yep which it is yes
if you cleanse why it was like that it
would still be yep okay all right now
this is exactly right but let me try and
explain it in another way because you
you've made the right conclusion but I'm
not sure if everyone's following
come back to this autumn at which oxygen
is very helpful okay because here you're
under it's one and then it's gonna be
like one point one and then 1.2 0.3 now
it's going to grow pretty slowly it's
gonna slow down forever but never stops
never becomes decreasing or anything
like that okay so therefore if this is
gonna get bigger forever then it's going
to scale from here like if I multiply by
one all the way then I just stay on this
green line up here my quiz X but I'm not
multiplying by one I'm multiplying by
numbers that are getting bigger and
bigger and bigger right so the only way
that you would curve away from this is
if you multiply by numbers that were
smaller than one but were less than one
right so for example if I was not to
moon by like nine tenths and then eight
nights or whatever right then you're
gonna start to curve away right but
you're always gonna be above this line
and you've in fact got a curve away from
it because what you're multiplying by is
bigger and bigger and bigger it is
slower but it's still bigger is the
important thing right so therefore even
though this guy is concave down the
composit is not concave down
okay the tunnel is concave up and that's
a bit tricky that logic step was hard to
make okay but in fact that he's gonna
keep on going away okay does that make
sense so in fact it is gonna get steep
up that was hard I know there's one more
way you can see it in order to like you
can see what's happening here right in
order for it to turn around you need
some kind of stationary point in here or
some change in concavity but there's
nothing happening right do you see that
these kinds of behaviors I just
preserved okay so they're just going to
keep on doing whatever they were doing
before maybe slightly slower but not
enough to actually turn something around
okay